la météo avec vers l'est au spécialiste
de l'assainissement individuel et de la
récupération d'eau de pluie
www.valeo.com de vous retrouver galles
le dantec sur la première c'est lord du
lundi politique avec aujourd'hui votre
invité vanessa miranville qui va arriver
voilà exactement je suis michel bonjour
notre invité qui devrait pas tarder dans
les à proximité de la station à cette
heure-là on attend donc d'autres invités
dans quelques instants
dans la tempête du mouvement des gilet
jaune les élus ont été fortement secoué
la démocratie questionné dans son
fonctionnement
et parmi ces élus une à lever le doigt
pour dire moi ça fait longtemps que je
pense à la démocratie locale autrement
que jules plaide pour la démocratie
participative
une élue qui a tenté aussi de dépasser
les clivages partisans fustigée par les
gilet jaune au pouvoir depuis quatre ans
maintenant elle a pourtant dû faire face
à de nombreuses critiques des frondes
des grèves même au sein de sa mairie
jugé un peu autoritaire solitaire dans
ses choix
elle tente de se fabriquer une ligne
politique l'image dans une certaine
diversité son mouvement citoyen à la
réunion de la réunion action n'a pas
réussi pour l'instant à dépasser sa
commune même si la présenter une
candidate lors des dernières élections
sénatoriales
vanessa miranville maire de la
possession vice présidente du tc aux
présidentes donc du créa est l'invité
lundi politique sur la première jusqu'à
13 heures elle ne devrait pas tarder à
arriver
vous pourrez vous posez vos questions à
notre invité
c'est à partir de 12h45 vous composez 02
62 90 2006 vous accueillera au standard
pour poser vos questions donc à vanessa
miranville à partir de 12h45
on attend
qui devrait me sens pas tardé arrive à
parler on va parler politique politique
évidemment on va parler on va revenir
avec sursis notamment le mouvement des
jeux les jeux parce que elle a été de
ces élus qui ont disons depuis des
années créée essayez de parler de
démocratie participative de démocratie
locale de créer des choses au niveau de
sa commune avec parfois des oppositions
des échecs et des réussites elle va nous
dire un petit peu comment ça fonctionne
et pour elle cette démocratie locale et
participative dans sa commune de la
possession va parler aussi du décès dans
le territoire de la complète puisqu'elle
en est l'une des vice présidentes et
notamment sur les questions
d'environnement les questions qui sont
dans l'actualité on le savait que les
questions qui se posent en ce moment sur
l'aménagement de la saline
ça sera peut-être une des questions sur
lesquelles vous pourrez l'interrogé vous
sur laquelle en tout cas moi je
l'intention d'interroger entre jours
merci merci d'être avec avec nous j'ai
30 ans et plus aux auditeurs que on va
parler des bras ce parti on va parler
aux 6 e enfants de commencer par ça dans
l'actualité c'est la polémique autour
d'une opération la saline-les-bains
collectif dénonce un déboisement très
destructeur notamment pour les endormis
et le tc aux dons vous êtes donc une
vice présidente explique qu'il s'agit de
lutter contre les inondations ces
parties de la réglementation de lutter
contre ces inondations est ce que vous
suivez vous père s'en soucier
alors je l'avais suivi quand il a eu l à
la problématique des banians 2
de la saline en fait quand on parle de
développement durable il faut vraiment
regarder l'ensemble des aspects est ce
que on peut se dire qu'on veut conserver
des arbres ou des espèces animales au
détriment de la sécurité des habitants
de la zone je pense que qu'effectivement
il faut peser le pour et le contre il
faut regarder aussi quel est l'impact
financier parce que les finances des
collectivités ne sont pas extensibles
par exemple sur le sur la sphère des
banians il a été décidé de maintenir ces
bagnes en mai le coût va être de trois
cent mille euros pour déplacer la digue
par rapport à son emplacement initial
puis de 50000 euros par an de
d'entretien parce que les racines des
banians sont extrêmement commentaires
s'étendent extrêmement vite est-ce qu'on
n'aurait pas mieux fait de planter des
dizaines et des centaines d'arbres sur
la forêt sèche de du live plus à la
grande chaloupe pour ces mêmes montants
financiers
voilà moi je pense que qu'effectivement
il faut jamais regarder un problème par
une seule lorgnette et par par une seule
entrée il faut vraiment toujours avoir à
l'esprit la complexité des choses et et
tous les paramètres sur ce sujet
précisément de de la saline avec ce
verdict on est en train de de l'été de
déboiser mais on ne prend en compte que
les risques d'inondation par la pluie et
et non pas les
les autres sorties inondations et
finalement problème si c'est le cas il
faut effectivement que des études
complémentaires soit faite et qu'on
puisse savoir regarder à nouveau quand
je dis le sujet sous toutes ses coutures
maintenant est-ce que le
la problématique de l'endormi peut pas
être résolu par un déplacement de
l'animal sur une zone qui elle ne sera
pas concernée par les travaux et qui est
suffisamment proches pour qu'ils
puissent continuer à vivre que voilà sa
vie dans dormi et continuer à être à
proliférer c'est un mois je ne maîtrise
pas suffisamment le sujet pour pouvoir
le dire il ya des experts qui justement
sont là pour pour le faire mais nous les
politiques c'est vraiment notre rôle est
vraiment de regarder les sujets de façon
très transversale vous faites partie
vanessa miranville de de celles qui ont
choisi de ne pas aller rencontres du
grand débat national pourquoi alors pour
plusieurs raisons déjà une raison très
pratique c'est que j'avais moi ce jour
là et le lendemain les voeux du maire à
mes agents et aux citoyens
possessionnais cd rendez vous
extrêmement important dans dans la vie
municipale et dans la vie d'un maire que
d'être au contact de ceux qui
travaillent au quotidien pour améliorer
le cadre de vie c'est pas votre seule
raison non non je disais il y en a
plusieurs ça c'est une raison pratique
mais qui est vraiment importante parce
que quand on écoute ce qui a été dit ces
derniers temps on parle par le mouvement
social d gilet jaune c'est nos élus ne
nous représente plus et quand est-ce
qu'on ne représente plus si on est
déconnecté si on écoute quand on n'est
pas à l'écouté de ce que peuvent dire
les agents des mairies qui sont eux
aussi au contact des citoyens au
quotidien et puis les citoyens
directement la l'autre raison on va dire
plus politique
c'est que moi j'estime caves et de deux
types de sujets les sujets d'ordre
régionaux à l'échelle de la réunion et
les sujets d'ordre nationaux au niveau
des sujets régionaux la réunion s'est
déjà largement exprimé via les assises
des outre mer via le moment dg les
jeunes et la venue de la ministre
j'estime que j'ai pas la légitimité à le
redire encore d'autres choses déjà il
faudrait que tout ce qui a été acté et
promis soit mis en place
or on voit bien qu'on est tous dans la
tente de concrétisation depuis la venue
de
l'âme gérardin donc ça c'est d'une part
ça et ensuite au niveau national je
n'estime pas non plus avoir la
légitimité à pouvoir parler au nom de
mes citoyens sur les sujets d'ordre
nationaux d'ordre national maintenant
toujours dans cette volonté de faire
participer les citoyens ya le grand
débat qui a été lancé moi j'ai proposé
gg médiatisé ça auprès des citoyens de
la réunion d'ailleurs pas que de la
possession que si des citoyens veulent
organiser le grand débat nous on donne
la salle on organise la garde des
enfants pour permettre que les femmes
aussi puissent être là parce que souvent
c'est c'est ça la problématique très
très concrète des femmes la garde
d'enfants et voilà on en communiquera
largement donc là on a déjà cinq
citoyens qui est positionné et
d'ailleurs qui sont manifestés qui se
rencontrent en sept semaines pour caler
des dates
a priori ce sera les samedis 23 février
et 2 mars matinée sur la possession on
va en faire quoi de ce qui sort de ce
grand débat là ça dépend pas de moi non
plus moi j'organise jeu permet que les
choses se passent il ya tout un
processus donc de ou de comptes rendus
qui est prévue avec un animateur qui a
été désigné par la préfecture avec
lequel donc j'étais en contact et qui
sera l'animateur de ces réunions qui
fera les comptes rendus qui les enverra
maintenant j'espère vraiment que ça sera
pris en compte parce que c'est clair que
si les gens ont pris la peine de se
déplacer de venir débattre et en même
temps c'est déjà intéressant rien que
que de réfléchir collectivement ça
passait déjà enrichissant en soi mais
c'est sûr que si ça n'est pas suivi
d'effet concret il y aura vraiment une
grande désillusion est une grande
déception encore plus grandes que celles
qu'on a déjà vu ces derniers temps et ça
sera vraiment terrible est ce que pour
l'instant de ce que vous sentez de ce
qui se passe dans la population des
retours vous avez ce que vous avez
entendu ce mouvement jugé que ces
revendications peuvent
être entendu par le pouvoir en place est
ce que vous avez l'impression qu'à la
façon dont les marocains se rendent et
parce que ça peut déboucher sur une
forme de compromis de réponse
satisfaisante parce que on va dans le
mur
moi je suis toujours quelqu'un
d'optimiste je veux pas décider que le
combat est perdu d'avancé avant même
d'avoir lancé les choses donc je pars du
principe que si effectivement il ya une
écoute sincère et une analyse profonde
de l'ensemble des contributions qu'ils
vont revenir vers le gouvernement il
peut en ressortir des choses très
intéressantes et des actions très
concrètes qui vont aller dans le sens de
ce que souhaitent les citoyens mais
toujours avec l'idée que on a des
finances qui sont leurs contraintes qu
on a aussi des équilibres à avoir moi
j'ai beaucoup aimé la formule de nicolas
hulot concilier les problèmes de fin de
mois et les problèmes de fin du monde
ne jamais oublier que voilà on a des
problèmes sociaux concret et immédiat
mais il ya aussi les problèmes
écologiques de plus long terme qui si on
les réseaux pas non si on en prendra
compte maintenant vont nous amener à des
situations tellement grave que les
problèmes sociaux seront minimes à côté
donc voila moi je moi je fais confiance
au processus qui est lancé moi j'estime
que c'est dommage qu'il est on est
attendu qu'il y ait tous ces mouvements
pour pour se lancer dans cette
participation citoyenne
mais comme on dit vaut mieux tard que
jamais certains sujets ont été abordés
comme lors du débat les élus d'outre-mer
à l'elysée on prend autant que le
président de la réplique était prêt à
étudier la question des rémunérations
des forces et pertinents moi j'ai un
principe qui est de ne jamais avoir de
sujets tabous ne jamais avoir d'à priori
et de toujours considérer que tout peut
être remis en question ont discuté
amélioré surtout amélioré
donc vous avez un avis sur la question
moi je suis
je vais moi même fonctionnaire et je
sais que la surrémunération est un sujet
un peu tabou à la réunion voire très
tabou à la réunion que c'est aussi un
sujet qui crée un sentiment d'injustice
de la part de ceux qui ne sont pas
fonctionnaires et qui ont l'impression
qu'il ya une réunion à deux à deux
vitesses voire à trois vitesses les
fonctionnaires les non fonctionnaires et
ceux qui ne travaillent même pas voilà
s'il faut de la justice sociale et que
ça passe par un questionnaire la
surrémunération après l'art questionner
ça veut pas forcément dire changer celle
qui est existante pour ceux qui sont
déjà fonctionnaires ça peut aussi
vouloir dire on la modifie pour ceux qui
vont devenir fonctionnaire dans les
années à venir
voilà donc moi je jeu steam que tout
doit pouvoir être discuté par contre il
faut vraiment que ce soit une discussion
éclairée franches
on va là sans se retourner dans la
polémique inutile quand on est maire
d'une commune comme la possession
c'est une question qu'on vit aussi quand
on fait le budget quand on embauche
qu'est-ce que ça pèse ça pèse énormément
la masse salariale sur une un budget de
communes c'est de l'ordre de 60 % pour
certaines jusqu'à 70 donc forcément tout
le reste est contraint les projets
qu'ils soient de fonctionnement ou
d'investissement sont tous contraints
par la masse salariale donc on est
obligé de réfléchir à l'agent prêt est
ce que oui ou non on fait cette embauche
ou pas et on a vraiment cette difficulté
à la réunion parfois même à trouver les
personnes adéquates sur sur certains
postes donc ces deux enjeux là font que
ça n'est pas simple de d'avoir les
bonnes personnes à la bonne place dans
les collectivités et en même temps que
ce soit à des coûts acceptables pour la
collectivité
à propos d'emploi le président n'a pas
l'intention de revenir sur la question
des emplois
dit ça marche pas savaria votre avis
quand quand l'annoncé faite l'an dernier
de diminution ou est-ce que vous en êtes
aujourd'hui soumis bon d'accord moi ma
position a toujours été de dire je suis
ok sur l'idée que les emplois aidés ont
été dévoyés je pense à un faux faut être
clair de leur fonction initiale qui est
l insertion des gens s'étaient pas le
turnover en mode kleenex je te prends un
an et puis tu vas aux assedic un an et
puis tu reviendras dans un an
voilà moi je vois cet état d'esprit chez
les gens j'en ai reçu encore des
personnes vendredi qui me disaient mais
moi ça fait plusieurs années que j'ai
passées pour la mairie alors que j'en
vois qui tue qui bossent
on bossait l'année dernière et que vous
allez bientôt reprendre donc il ya
vraiment cette idée que ça doit être un
truc de tournant pour que tout le monde
puisse en profiter
ça va à l'encontre d'une autre principe
que manger c'est aussi la pérennisation
et la professionnalisation des gens
c'est à dire que je prends le cas
extrême pour moi c'est celui des atsem
quand on veut des personnes compétentes
s'y colle mais voilà dans les écoles
d'internet on veut que nos petits bouts
d'choux soit vraiment quand on s'en
occupe bien et avec des personnes
professionnels on peut pas faire que
c'est soit des personnes qui tous les
ans doivent se sont sans nouvelles
l'enfant n'est pas n'est pas habitué
alors des fois en plus ça se passe en
milieu d'année et qu'on doit à nouveau
former le temps de la formation de la
personne c'est aussi du temps de verdure
vous avez les moyens de pérenniser ses
emplois
alors on prend les moyens on trouve des
économies par ailleurs pour permettre de
pérenniser ses emplois et par exemple en
deux années on est passé de 45 % à 65 %
d'emplois pérennes sur ce poste des
atsem et on veut arriver d'ici 2 à 3
années à 100 % d'emplois pérennes sur ce
poste parce qu'on estime qu'il est
vraiment crucial
on essaye de le faire aussi sur d'autres
types de postes que ce soit les services
techniques où justement il ya une
technicité
on prend pas un peintre
novice et il n'a pas la même expérience
que quelqu'un qui est peint depuis cinq
à dix ans voilà il ya des métiers comme
ça est ce que vous le dis vous disiez
pardon vous disiez que vous avez encore
des gens qui on essaye à ce beau alors
non on essaye de trouver d'autres
solutions
clairement les mairies ne peuvent pas
fournir l'emploi nécessaire pour toute
une commune ce n'est pas ce sera l'heure
de faire penser aux gens que c'est le
cas par contre on a un rôle avec les
intercommunalités d'essayer de créer de
l'emploi dans d'autres secteurs je
prends un cas très concret on est en
train de regarder à mettre des appels à
projets économiques sur l'ensemble du
foncier communal qui restent en friche
c'est à dire au lieu de laisser des
terrains en friche et en a partout dans
toutes les communes soit on en fait des
jardins partagés parce que ça aussi
c'est important pour le lien social
ou alors on lance des appels à projets
pour des de la création de commerces de
la création de bureaux etc
donc voilà on favorise les l'emploi les
échos boxe que saint denis a lancé pour
les petits artisans etc
c'est une des jeux trouve très
intéressante qu'on est en train aussi de
regarder on regarde au niveau du tissu
associatif
les associations ont elles aussi besoin
d'emplois les encadrants sportifs les
les admis la gestion administrative
parce qu'une association qui brasse plus
de 100000 euros par exemple ne peut pas
le faire si elle n'a pas une gestion
extrêmement go rigoureuse de ses
finances de son administration etc
donc on regarde comment pérenniser des
emplois aussi dans le milieu associatif
le milieu on va dire globale de
l'économie sociale et solidaire donc il
ya d'autres pistes que simplement
l'emploi de en mairie maintenant je
reviens sur ce que je disais pour autant
les emplois aidés même si je suis prête
à accepter l'idée qu'il faille une vraie
insertion et pas le lancer un système
qui a été faux le dire très clientéliste
et très voilà c'est ici je temple wat u
boat pour moi etc
il faut malgré tout un temps
de latence et nous accompagner sur une
autre voie avant de nous enlever ses
employés parce qu'on se retrouve dans la
situation sociale
je suis persuadé que la crise et gilet
jaune et est en partie due à la
diminution des emplois aidés assez forte
qui a eu entre 2017 et 2018 le
gouvernement une grand partie des élus
sont d'accord pour la création d'emplois
elle en parle et vient doit venir de
l'activité économique est ce que sur
l'activité économique il faut qu'il faut
compter ou sur la lire en public
comment est ce que vous vous situez vous
par rapport à ça il ya un entre-deux un
bien sûr c'est ni ni complètement
lannion complètement l'autre moi je suis
vraiment dans l'idée du partenariat
public privé
je prends un exemple très concret on
assure coeur de ville vraiment monter
une zac qui est innovante en termes de
gouvernance c'est à dire que d'habitude
c'est le public qui arrivent et qui
décident d'exproprier tout le monde et
ensuite de construire la zac et ça met
des dizaines d'années parfois parce que
les propriétaires ne veulent pas ça
finit devant les tribunaux sur le coeur
de ville
on savait qu'on avait des logements des
commerces des bureaux à construire et
que tout ça était extrêmement urgent
pour le bien-être des citoyens et donc
on a monté une structure mixte dans
laquelle il ya à la fois les
propriétaires des propos des promoteurs
et l'aménageur qui est classée madère et
le fait de veut d'avoir mis en place la
structure mixte et public privé permet
qu'au bout de quatre ans
déjà 400 logements construits on a les
premiers commerces qui sont sortis et
dès l'année prochaine on démarre la
deuxième tranche où on aura une
trentaine de commerces supplémentaires
plus des bureaux donc voila et de
l'emploi donc qui va se créer un peu
près sans une centaine d'emplois qui va
se créer sur car deux villes d'ici deux
à trois ans ce qu'il faut aider les
entreprises qu'il faut aller fiscalité
allégée
on a vu qu'avec cice qui avait coûté
très cher aux finances publiques avec
d'emploi à mesurer est ce qu'il faut
aller dans cette voie là qu'il ya
d'autres y en a pas d'autre
aujourd'hui ce d'accord on a les
entreprises mais à condition c'est clair
ne jamais donner un chèque en blanc
je prends un petit échelle ce que ce
qu'on fait nous mairie vis-à-vis des
associations
on a des critères pour leur attribuer
des subventions et ensuite on a un
contrôle a posteriori contrôle de
gestion pour vérifier que celles qui ont
en tout cas le plus de subventions est
bien utilisé l'argent à bon escient
on ne peut pas donner à des entreprises
de l'argent public sans leur exiger des
comptes rendus et un des résultats
attendus en fin de en fin de parcours et
si elle n'irait si elle ne le respecte
pas de plus leur donner c'est évidemment
et dans vos dans vos propositions j'en
avais fait quelques-unes
il faut que les entreprises il faut oui
je pense qu'il faut les baisser pour
aider les revenus en moins oui oui mais
de toute façon on le paye autrement nous
le fait que les gens ne soient pas
employé va faire que ben on va ça va
nous générer de l'aide sociale par
exemple supplémentaire voire deux des
réparations parce que on aura plus de
délinquance c'est à dire que ces baisses
de taxes doivent être accompagnées d'une
obligation de créer le danger
oui oui pour moi clairement il doit y
avoir une autre échelle si vous en avez
parlé avec le medef
ils sont d'accord alors je n'ai pas
encore rencontré les medef j'ai discuté
avec lacets pme qui je pense est ouverte
à cette idée là parce que ceux qui sont
le plus embêté pour créer des emplois
vis-à-vis des détaxes forte c'est plutôt
les petites et moyennes entreprises
voire les tpe que les grandes
entreprises
et moi je rencontre souvent des petits
artisans des petits entrepreneurs qui me
dit mais mais moi je suis tout seul je
suis en train de de crouler sous le
travail je suis à 80 heures par semaine
je rêverais pouvoir embaucher mais ça me
coûterait tellement cher que je ne peux
pas donc du coup je continue tout seul
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur la
question la démocratie posées par le
mouvement des jeunes comment est-ce que
vous
vous avez vécu cette cette violence
verbale en tout cas très très très forte
contre les élus locaux les locaux dans
l'ensemble vous trompez comment est ce
que vous l'avez vécu bon forcément pas
voilà c'est jamais très agréable de se
sentir attaqué après bon moi je me suis
largement exprimé en disant ne mettons
pas tout le monde dans le même panier de
soissons les généralités sont jamais
très très bonne et très vrai donc
faisons la part des choses entre des
élus qu'effectivement abuse et certain
niveau des lieux déjà effectivement les
députés européens qui sont en casiers à
15000 euros d'indemnités par par mois
c'est indécent le niveau national de
façon générale à des niveaux
d'indemnisation qui sont indécents par
contre au niveau local on n'est pas du
tout à la même enseigne
un mec comme moi sur une commune de plus
de 30000 habitants ses 1700 euros
d'indemnités plus 1900 au niveau de la
vice-présidente de l'interco voilà donc
avec les deux je retrouve un niveau de
revenu qui équivaut à ce que je touchais
en tant que fonctionnaire en tant que
prof
voilà je n'estime pas volé la mama par
d'argent public au vu de le bas de
l'investissement que j mais maintenant
c'est clair que tout est une question
aussi d'investissement est ce que on
touche ces indemnités là et on ne fait
rien ou est ce qu'on est vraiment acteur
l'élection et à un moment où on peut
s'exprimer et sanctionner ceux qui est
qu'ils n'ont pas joué le jeu
maintenant voilà je sens que c'est cette
ce désamour on va dire du citoyen vers
le politique il est quand même très très
large
moi je j'ai pris mon parti il ya
quelques années vous avez vous avez la
transparence vous avez
une des questions posées par régis mais
au delà ça il ya la représentativité qui
est posé vous avez vous souvent défendu
les idées de démocratie participative
est ce que vous avez pu l'expérimenter
est ce que ça peut fonctionner
visiblement il y avait la possession ils
ont pas été convaincus par votre façon
de faire la politique
à moi je les ai rencontrés quatre ou
cinq fois le gilet jaune pendant le
mouvement et puis avant-hier encore je
suis passé les voir dans leur maison
citoyenne
ça se passe très bien les relations sont
très bonnes dans le sens où ils savent
qu'on est je parle de mon équipe et moi
on est vraiment des gens qui essayons
d'écouter au mieux les citoyens
donc oui la démocratie participative ça
fonctionne tous les ans la possession il
ya plus de mille personnes qui
s'expriment sous différentes formes ça
peut être des sondages officiels
représentatif avec ipsos ou d'autres
organismes
ça peut être des sondages plus léger sur
sur internet y en a trois en ce moment
par exemple on veut savoir où les gens
pensent qu'il y aurait besoin de
ralentisseurs pour la sécurité dans nos
rues on cherche un nom
approprié pour la nouvelle école de
coeur de ville et tous les mois on
changera de quartier un point sur les
actions déjà réalisées les actions qui y
sont prévus pour 2010 9 pour vérifier si
elles correspondent bien aux attentes
des gens voilà donc il ya des réunions
publiques il ya des groupes de citoyens
acteurs qui font des embellissements une
fois par mois
voilà il ya plein de choses qui se passe
et où les citoyens nous dise enfin vous
nous donnez là le pouvoir soit d'agir
souhaite parler et d'être entendue
est ce que ça vous est arrivé de changer
la vie dans une consultation ou est-ce
qu'elles servent finalement validé qui a
déjà été décidé en tant que donc élue
dans un jeu qui sont a été élu pour
prendre des décisions
alors ça dépend des sujets parce que
c'est clair qu'on ne peut pas consulter
tout le monde sur tous les sujets donc
il faut aussi être réaliste sur le temps
et l'énergie dont on dispose et
notamment les services qui sont là aussi
pour faire des choses donc on essaye
autant que possible de faire les
consultations de plus en amont possible
par exemple je prends l'exemple très
connu de la carrière des lataniers les
associations car lataniers notre coeur
de vie a été consultée dès 2016 dès le
lancement de
de notre réflexion sur le sujet une fois
qu'on a fait le tour avec la région et
vu que ben on avait pas de possibilité
de garder les financements que la région
nous promettez sans avoir la
contrepartie on va dire de
l'exploitation de la carrière donc dès
qu'on l'a on a vu qu'il y avait plus
plus cette option va évidemment qui nous
aurait quand qu'on aurait préféré
on a consulté ce collectif et les
citoyens de façon générale voilà donc
plus on le fait en amont effectivement
mieux c'est parce que sinon les gens ont
le sentiment qu'on vient la halle pour
la forme pour pour juste avoir une sorte
de caution morale et non la démocratie
participative s'il ya bien une chose qui
doit être clair c'est que ça doit être
sincère et authentique
si on n'est pas là pour vraiment écouter
les gens ça ne sert à rien je prends un
autre exemple sur lequel on a
effectivement changé notre fusil
d'épaulé en partie c'est sur
l'extinction des déclarations publiques
c'est quelque chose qui nous tenait à
coeur
ben pour des raisons économiques
écologiques et aussi de santé pour les
les êtres humains et la biodiversité
on a vu que c'était quelque chose qui ne
plaisait pas vraiment parce que les gens
n'aiment pas être dans le noir même si
c'est qu'entre minuit quatre heures dont
qu'on a gardé allumer les rues
principale et on a fait un changement
d'éclairage public d'un tiers de
l'éclairage et d'ici deux à trois ans
grâce tout changer au permettre de
rallumer l'éclairage un peu moins fort
avec des économies d'énergie et des
économies financières mais malgré tout
répondre à cette demande les gilet jaune
une partie d'entre eux veulent aller
plus loin ils veulent voir s'ils n'ont
pas passé mais nous cratie direct par un
système de référendum le faire d'ici par
exemple est ce que vous faites une
différence ya une frontière que vous
mettez entre démocratie participative
qu'elle votre rôle d'élu justement la
démocratie directe pour moi elle déjà
elle ne peut pas s'appliquer à tous il
ya tellement de décisions dans une
journée
je dois prendre une centaine de
décisions si si toutes ces décisions
devaient passer par le biais d'une
démocratie directe
les choses seraient extrêmement
ralenties et donc ça serait
contre-productif par rapport à ce que
les gens veulent où ils nous disent
justement ça va pas assez vite les
administrations vous vous prenez trop de
temps donc moi je pense que qu'elle peut
être étudiée mais sur un nombre très
limité de sujets les sujets vraiment
très important
et ce n'est qu'après dans le quotidien
la démocratie participative est vraiment
la meilleure fin le conseil consultatif
citoyen la région avec des jeux qui
serait au sort d'accord ce constat
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous c'est
bien de partir sur un conseil citoyen
c'est bien qu'ils soient tirés au sort
aussi parce que nous c'est vrai qu'on
n'a pas encore expérimenté ça mais on
l'a on a les dents dans les tuyaux de se
dire on constate que ceux qui
s'impliquent dans toutes les instances
de participation
sauf dans les sondages etc ou là c'est
plus plus plus mixé entre les hommes et
femmes les jeunes etc
mais sinon quand il s'agit de venir
physiquement à une réunion
ça a tendance plutôt être à dos d homme
d'un certain âge on a peu de jeunes on a
plus de femmes
donc c'est pour ça la garde d'enfants
déjà pour avoir un peu plus de parité
mais pour les jeunes voilà on a on n'a
pas encore par le numérique pas encore
trouvé le bon filon donc on se dit que
le tirage au sort en disant on veut
qu'ils aient autant d'hommes que de
femmes
une représentation selon l'âge et selon
aussi les quartiers selon la catégorie
sociale représentatives de la population
c'est une bonne chose
maintenant ce par quoi les légers les
jeunes sont passés ou sont en train de
passer ou ce conseil consultatif de la
région où on voit que que les gens
n'arrivent pas forcément à se mettre
d'accord
nous on est passé par là et ça a fait
des remous quant au début de mon mandat
voilà il ya eu des soubresauts au sein
même de ma majorité
mais je pense que c'est un passage
obligé de d'un changement de façon de
faire
de la démocratie et on ne peut pas y
couper maintenant clairement il faut pas
que ce soit ceux qui parlent le plus
fort qui s'expriment le mieux ou qui ont
entre guillemets le plus grand le plus
gros ego qui qu'ils soient ceux qui
mènent la barque parce que sinon le
résultat peut être assez catastrophique
donc comment garantir l'éthique c'est
toute la question
dans un instant va prend des questions
de des auditeurs vous appeler au 02 99
2000 mais vous avez évoqué la nouvelle
avis du conseil national party font
assure le projet sur le héros du
littoral qui dit avoir d'impact négatif
avéré d'insuffisance renconte
d'incertitudes relatives aux impacts
environnementaux aux conséquences
prévisibles dit ce rapport de la
réalisation prochaine la ligue de la
digue sur remblais ce que vous qui avez
été écologistes ce projet peut-être
qu'il ya encore trop de l'oif alors bien
sûr qu'il m'a interpellé ce rapport du
cnpn
on a beau regarder en détail ce qu'on
est en train de valider c'est un
courrier adressé à la région ont demandé
d'apporter des précisions par rapport à
ce rapport du cnpn par rapport aux 6
abbas que le collectif contre la digue a
pu avancer
je pense que à nouveau la transparence
est vraiment de mise dans des sujets
aussi complexes que cela et aussi avec
un enjeu aussi fort pour tous les
réunionnais maintenant arrêter un
chantier qui est déjà pour lequel les
marchés sont déjà signés ça veut dire 5
à 10% d'indemnisation des entreprises
donc sur dix ont un milliard d'euros ça
ferait du 500 millions à un milliard de
pardon 50 millions à 100 millions
d'euros qu'il faudrait donner à ces
entreprises dans la réalisation est ce
qu'on les prix a ajouté cet argent
public comme ça moi ce qui m'interpelle
c'est que ce rapport à interviennent
aussi tard pourquoi il n'a pas été donné
il ya cinq ans il ya dix ans pourquoi
maintenant et expliquer encore existait
déjà
parce qu'il confirme
après mois des échos que j'ai même là
des halles est interpellé sur le contenu
du rapport et son ex en arriver à ce
moment précis la falaise
ce qu'il dit c'est que la falaise
s'effondre on le sait tous que la
falaise s'effondre il ya aucune des
mesures de compensation n'est citée dans
le rapport à ce qu'ils les ont évalués
ces mesures de compensation est ce que
dans les faits elle compense bien où
elles sont insuffisantes
voilà moi je vois là ce rapport est
intéressant mais je trouve qu'il manque
des éléments et en tout cas il faut
absolument que la région apporte des
éclaircissements de son côté est ce que
la nécessité finalement pour didier
robert d'ouvrir les carrières pour faire
cette selle trousses dans le schéma
actuel sa création de dépendance entre
vous maire de la possession et la région
l'alliance qui va au-delà de la question
finalement des carrières qui crée une
dépendance politique c'est quelque chose
que moi qui ai un peu délicat mais oui
clairement j'ai un peu le sentiment de
ne pas être complètement libre de des
choix pour la commune maintenant comme
je ne suis pas du genre à accepter ce
sentiment d'être un peu coincés on a
regardé à nouveau ce dossier sont tous
sous toutes ses coutures et on l'a
regardé sous l'angle de l'opportunité
on se dit que effectivement cette route
du littoral en tout cas si elle se fait
tel que telle qu'elle est prévue
actuellement on veut y participer parce
que nous on est aux premières loges et
aux premiers on est les premiers à être
impactée à être pénalisés dès que la
route du littoral se ferment on est
asphyxié pour être clair ensuite on est
associés de façon générale au niveau
circulation à la possession comme
beaucoup comme dans plein d'autres
endroits la réunion donc il faut en tout
cas que le dossier avant toi je veux
bien qu'on me pose des questions qui est
de la transparence
maintenant il faut pas que ce dossier
prenne encore deux ans cinq ans de
retard les réunionnais l'attend depuis
trop longtemps
ce règlement de cette traversée entre
saint denis et la possession
les auditeurs peuvent nous appeler au 02
62 99 2006 ont des questions pour
vanessa miranville qui tous jusqu'à 13
heures pour prolonger cette question de
la dépendance
politique est ce que dans le grand
échiquier de plus en plus confus
l'endiguer politique de la réunion
est-ce que vous sont plus aujourd'hui où
situez vous avez été vous disiez
écologistes vous avez 7,7 difficultés
éventuellement de relation avec
difficulté dépendance par rapport aux
10,3 vous n'êtes ni de gauche ni de
droite ni en marche
nicolau alors je redis j'ai pu sentir un
sentiment de dépendance mais que
qu'aujourd'hui je prends d'une autre
façon et au contraire je fais valoir les
projets de la possession on a obtenu par
exemple 3 millions d'euros de
subventions au titre du plan de relance
régional en compensation des
désagréments que la possession subie
face à ce chantier donc voilà la
dépendance n'est pas le terme
aujourd'hui de la relation entre la
région et la position c'est plutôt
maintenant un partenariat gagnant
gagnant
ensuite sur la position sur l'échiquier
politique effectivement oui je n'aime
pas être positionné parce que la réalité
n'est jamais aussi simple que de dire je
suis gosse de gauche de droite je suis
écolo je suis socialiste moi clairement
et je pense que ça les gens le savent
maintenant je prône un développement
durable de la réunion de ma commune pour
commencer parce qu'il faut bien
commencer quelque part qu'on traitement
et de la rime est donc le pilier
économique
le pilier social et sociétal et le
pilier environnemental sont tout aussi
un port important et si on me dit il
faut choisir un des trois je dis non non
c'est pas possible de dire que l'être
humain est plus important que la nature
parce qu'on peut pas vivre sans la
nature ou que l'économique est plus
important que le bien-être des citoyens
non tout est lié
on est bien si on a un travail si on est
si on la trouve sa place dans sa société
si on est au milieu d'une nature qui
nous permet d'être dans commandé un
bien-être au quotidien et la nature
en ville est importante pour faire
baisser les températures regarder les
températures qu'on est en train de subir
si on peut si on bétonne tout on se
retrouvera à avoir des problèmes de
santé en europe
donc voilà tout est interdépendant et
moi je suis une élue du développement
durable je comprends bien que vous en
dehors de les clivages traditionnels des
parties
malgré tout pour l'instant sauf
évolution très prochaine
le système démocratique actuel fait que
les gens sont en général est élu dans un
gros dans un parti politique a fait
campagne avec voilà vous êtes les
séjours qui confirme la règle pas ce que
parce que c'est assez pour savoir pour
faire une campagne il faut la structure
il faut et il faut souvent passer des
alliances
donc ma question avec qui est ce que
vous pourriez passer des alliances qui
nous ne pourriez pas passer des
alliances sur des municipales c'est ce
qu'on avait fait en 2014
c'est vraiment je pense que le les
étiquettes n'ont pas beaucoup de sens on
est vraiment sûr de la proximité
donc moi je pourrais passer des
alliances sur l'élection de 2020 par
exemple uniquement avec des personnes ou
pour lesquels les tic seraient partagés
et la majeure partie on va dire des
projets qui découleraient de cette
éthique quand je parle d'éthique c'est
vraiment la volonté des transparents de
la démocratie participative
le respect de cet équilibre entre
l'économique le social et
l'environnemental
voilà donc ça c'est au niveau une
commune à la presse sur d'autres
d'autres niveaux le niveau régional
c'est un peu le même schéma
c'est clairement les valeurs moi je ne
crois pas on partage notre programme et
on regarde si on est d'accord parce que
si je n'ai pas regardé en amont comment
les personnes ont été quand elles ont
été élues est ce qu on estime qu'elles
ont été sincère et honnête entre
basquaise avait promis et ce qu'elles
ont fait
écrire des choses sur le papier c'est
trop facile donc clairement voilà le fil
conducteur c'est ce sont les valeurs et
la façon dont les personnes ont incarné
les valeurs qu'elle prône il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de partis politiques qu'ils
vous refuseriez de france à la réunion
il n'ya pas de partis extrêmes avec
lesquels je ne retrouverai pas c'est
clair par exemple front national alors
voilà pour moi nenê plus n'est pas du
tout en phase avec les valeurs que je
peux avoir après sur le reste non pour
on pourrait regarder mais clairement on
l'a vu en sait on a on s'est confronté à
la question en 2015 aux régionales quand
on a regardé on s'est dit non il n'y a
pas de candidat avec qui on se sent
suffisamment phase on avait monté
d'ailleurs une charte éthique qu'on
avait voulu faire signer aux candidats
il y en a pas un seul qui l'ait signé
donc voilà on préfère ne pas partir tout
court en deux comme ça a été en 2015 le
quart en 2015 ou partir seul très
probablement en 2021 au régional créé a
réfléchi à monter sa propre liste que de
partir en revenir je vous en ai tout mal
à ma lettre
on en est à voir j'ai un groupe on va
dire de discussions et de réflexions d'à
peu près sans quelques personnes 150
personnes baky qui est extrêmement
prolifique en idées maintenant on essaye
de passer à la phase d'après qui est la
structuration de ses idées thématique
par thématique
concrètement qu'est ce que la région
peut amener sur chacune des thématiques
voilà on en est là et on va on va
cheminer petit à petit pas de discussion
pour l'instant avec d autres noms noms
comme en avant de discuter avec les
autres il faut déjà avoir être au clair
avec soi même donc on commence par là
votre mouvement donc le le créa il était
pressenti être viable avec françoise
lambert
qui n'a pas dit dans son arrêt des
lumières et j'y prends c'est ça un échec
c'est une tâche aussi sur dans votre
volonté de leur couleur politique
alors oui ça et enfin surtout ça a été
un coup
pour nous parce que c'est une élue de
grande valeur c'est mon adjointe à
l'aménagement c'est la vie se présentent
au déplacement au tc haut et c'est
quelqu'un dont l'éthique est
complètement irréprochable et se
retrouvait inéligible souvent en général
les gens associent ça c'est quelqu'un
qui a volé concrètement sur un compte je
crois d'un millier d'euros la raison
pour laquelle elle est inéligible c'est
qu'une personne a fait un chèque en se
trompant en remettant un chèque au nom
de sa essayez donc une entreprise au
lieu d'un chèque personnel
et effectivement il ya un défaut de
contrôle et ce chèque n'était pas
valable parce que les entreprises ne
peuvent pas payer une campagne et parce
qu'on n'a pas fait appel à un expert
comptable
voilà parce que le compte était très
très minime un millier d'euros alors
général c'est des dizaines et centaines
de milliers d'euros dépensés deux
raisons la effectivement une éligibilité
qui qui nous nous fait mal au coeur mais
bon qui nous empêche pas de rebondir et
d'avancer dans un principe de ne jamais
rester là où on est on tombé toujours se
relever
voilà nous avons plusieurs standards on
va commencer par joseph qui je rêve
kindo dams et ça c'est très doux oui oui
on vous le ferez l'eau en écoute sur
cette question saviez-vous très bien et
moi j'aurai deux questions ou de devant
à faire j'ai mon petit fils qui va à
l'école ils varient de pamiers à la
possession
oui avant l'entrée de l'école là où les
parents vont accueillir leurs enfants
oui en temps de pluie yaker on vous
entend pas très bien frais de sous pour
vous rapprocher de votre téléphone vous
aviez une deuxième question
voilà bah là dessus juste pour dire
c'est un comment ce couloir va devenir
une voie piétonne qui relie chamand la
mairie l'église et le verger roston donc
il est déjà en projet de refaire tout le
l'enrobé et de faire vraiment que
qu'effectivement il est plus ce problème
de flaques d'eau que je connais vu que
j'étais moi même élève à l'école silva
ya trois ans de ça et effectivement
voilà les embouts un bon besoin de coup
de neuf sur sur cette petite voix ou
parce que c'est prévu
votre deuxième question fallu attendre
plus du tout alors on va prendre
désolé pour vous entendre on vous entend
plus on va prendre
eric au téléphone qui nous appellent
également la possession bonjour
vous avez déposé un courrier chez vous
oui tous les mairies aussi que la même
chose justement et aujourd'hui je n'ai
pas de retour là dessus votre os x avait
réfléchi sur les camelots
mais est-ce que tu efficace que vous est
ce que pour nous expliquer en quelques
mois quasiment un an dernier nous reste
nous 2010 de quoi les jeunes et puis on
avait des courriers sur la transparence
tous les mairies de la réunion c'est que
la région et le département et au jour
d'aujourd'hui je crois qu'on a pas
nouvelle c'était sur les indemnités des
élus ans c'est ça oui et ben non nous on
a déjà fait le point sur les indemnités
encore un conseil ce mercredi justement
parce que mécaniquement les indemnités
des élus ont augmenté au 1er enfin
peuvent augmenter au 1er janvier 2019
donc moi j'ai déjà fait la transparence
sur mon indemnité personnel donc j'ai
publié mes bulletins d'indemnités et la
réponse a été faite collectivement
maintenant je vais retrouver la réponse
il n'ya aucun souci au contraire on est
même allé est à les afficher
il n'y a pas de problème ce sont ces
voix là c'est laid c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait normal que les gens
sachent combien en touche et j'ai fait
même une motion à l'ensemble des
collectivités pour leur demander
d'appliquer la même chose que le tc eau
et la mairie de la possession à savoir
couper la moitié des indemnités si les
idées